[Music]
so one of the things first of all
Congrats on the movie one of the things
you guys are known for doing is plussing
the films and I believe it's one of your
secrets that helps make these movies
what they are now that the movies been
out and made a billion dollars what did
you Plus on Captain Marvel that you can
look at reveal isn't it weird when he
says this out and made a billion dollars
no plussing is not a secret we're very
open about blessing and I think we tried
to Plus every frame of it that's a good
answer is was there because listen
obviously when you show the movie you
will always notice you need to do
something or maybe there's a big action
set piece you still need to add whatever
it may be is there something in Captain
Marvel like anything big or cool that
got added from the plussing look at the
like Victoria said the plussing sort of
happens across the board I'm trying to
think of something in specific that we
really dug in on and I guess there was a
beat in the final battle that sort of
been in and out for a while the beat
where Captain Marvel has all of her
powers and she goes and take down all
those missiles before she flies up into
space and it felt as we were showing the
movie audiences and as we were going
through the post process like they just
wanted more of Captain Marvel using her
powers and having fun and the missiles
felt like this thing that even though we
had sort of taken it out of the movie
that sort of wanted to fight its way
back in so you know just as a kind of
small example of the plussing that felt
like one of those things that was a
late-breaking change that made the movie
better and I think one of the things
that we did instead of putting things in
it was taking out and I think that we
continuously tried to make sure that
this was not a male bashing film because
to give her her power we didn't need to
Mel bash it was really about empowering
her and I think depending on how the
movie you were seeing and how the rhythm
of the film there were times where it
felt like we were doing that not because
we were consciously trying but because
it was how the flow of it was so we kept
just taking things out that it was more
in her power as opposed to taken away
from you've worked on I believe all the
Marvel movies and you
I've been working on a number as well is
there something from the previous Marvel
movies like a sequence I'm going back
into plussing another question is there
something that got added that maybe fans
would be surprised to learn they got
added very late in the process we always
have things that are late in the process
but lateis I don't know what you mean by
late I mean I felt like two months
before release you're like oh we really
need to add this I guess not a term
unlike the sequence level I think you
know the bones of the movie estate
pretty much the same all the way through
one of the ideas that was sort of
late-breaking was the idea that Carroll
should sort of fly off with the scrolls
at the end of the movie that was that
was kind of a later idea it just felt
like she needed kind of more Drive and
to kind of fulfill the mission and the
legacy of Marvel in a more serious and
direct way that the audience understood
so we screed versions of the movie where
where that didn't happen and the end of
the movie was Carole kind of flying off
by herself and it didn't quite feel as
impactful as we wanted it to be or as an
emotional as we wanted it to be so we
sort of went back in the well in terms
of what else can this be and I think I
think Ryan and Anna came up with that
idea they did and I think it actually
tied this story much better so I have
some home video questions let's see if
you know any of the well just as a test
channel right do you know if there is
any plans for any 4k releases for the
older Marvel movies yes okay is there a
phase 3 box set coming uh I don't know
about that but I would like to buy one
let me know if you find out well the big
question of course is now that phase
three like a Spider Man is part of phase
3 but when that's done is there any sort
of plan for some epic 22 film 20 I don't
like 23 films yeah box set everything
yeah I guess we sort of have to write
and design like a really cool case where
the questions really even come with the
right case that we wait the case will be
like big well yes okay the right case
for phase one like the briefcase - it's
the or the case but by the way going
back to your other question we are going
to remaster all of our films in the 4k
we're in the process of doing that so
it's all happening because but I'm also
curious about obviously Disney Plus is
coming yes I am tremendously looking
forward to this thing but does that
impact the home video releases at all or
is it still going to be you know
physical
Media for the future movies you know
like spider-man whatever it may be like
or will it you know what I mean like how
does that work Disney Plus I don't think
that the physical DVD itself will ever
go away I don't think so if that's
happening they haven't told us but you
will be able to actually click Disney
Plus and there she is